good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you come out so you can have a positive
impact on yourself on your family your
community and the world so to help you
on your journey today's message is dream
big over to you Steve Jobs I think that
as you know right now the computer
industry is in the tank personal
computers big computers everything and
it's difficult it's a difficult time but
I'm sure that Henry Ford had a few bad
quarters back in the 1920s and the
automobile had a sort of historical
imperative it had the minute it was
invented a sequence of events had to
happen the same is true with the
personal computer there is a tremendous
momentum behind this and I think that
this year may be a delay this year we
may look back and say well 1985 was a
slow year but there is such momentum
behind this that it will happen it will
permeate and change forever our
educational processes and my hope again
is that not too many generations of
students will pass through before this
happens it will happen within 20 years
it probably will happen within 10 years
but it could happen within five years I
am going back to the United States this
weekend and then about two weeks from
today I'll be in the Soviet Union for
the first time in Moscow because one of
my dreams has been to sell Macintosh's
in the Soviet Union
and one of the highest agenda agendas
Amaya priority is to is to get them
starting to think about exactly the same
thing so maybe six months or a year year
and a half from now we can have some
Soviet schools here at our your a
consortium meeting it can be hard to
keep perspective when you hit a rough
patch it can be hard to stay sane and
stay motivated and stay optimistic when
you fall on tough times when something
doesn't go right when the market slows
down when you lose a big customer and
that's part of the game of being an
entrepreneur we're gonna have these
highs and lows but hopefully we're
moving forward in the positive direction
and part of winning as an entrepreneur
is just sticking with it it's just
staying on the path it's just everyday
getting up and being consistent and
moving forward you only really lose if
you give up right and so you can lose
little battles but if you keep going
you're gonna win the war and I think
what really helps you keep consistent
and keep motivated and keep on every day
getting up and fighting is remembering
the wives remembering your big dream the
big goal what you're trying to
accomplish and so for me I think about
untapped potential you know I think the
biggest problem in the world is untapped
human potential I think if we can solve
that we solve all the major problems of
the world and I think the way to help
untap people or help to unlock them help
bring out that potential is through the
environment right you may not have that
with your friends and your family your
parents the people around you but you
can get that from the books and videos
and the resources that you watching
consume and so it's why I created this
YouTube channel so what keeps me
motivated on a daily basis is thinking
about that big problem the biggest
problem the world is facing is untapped
human potential and if I can create
content that slowly moves people forward
slowly helps unlock a little bit of
potential if you keep hearing the same
message multiple times from different
people slowly it starts to seep in right
the more time you spend around
successful people the more you want to
become successful the more you adopt
their mindset and positivity and the
more you hang around
people who are not accomplishing things
who are complaining and who are negative
the more you're gonna be like those
people and so my solution is to create
that for you for myself I want to be
around
uber successful people and have their
mindset seep into me and so whenever
things don't go my way
whenever a series doesn't work out
whenever something happens you know life
is gonna happen problems are gonna
happen in business it's never just a
straight line up whenever those things
happen in my business people often asked
well how do you stay optimistic how do
you study you stay go on how are you so
positive all the time what's because I
believe in where we're going right like
I have a big dream I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs I want to help
unlock potential and I believe that the
way to do it is through the environment
and so even though this one thing didn't
work out it's not everything right it's
being able to step out from the trees to
see the forest to see the big picture so
it may have lost one battle but I'm
still fighting the war and I'm gonna
have an impact and I'm gonna make a
difference and so just reminding myself
of the why what I'm trying to accomplish
why I'm doing it
that gets me fired up again to overcome
whatever short term hassles or problems
that I'm facing and so the question of
the day I have for you is what is your
big dream what's the thing that gets you
excited that keeps you motivated that
keeps you working hard every day even
when you might lose a battle share it
down the counsel below I'm excited to
see it and I think writing it down can
help you you know remember why you're
doing this and could also potentially
inspire the other people watching to
help them chase their dreams as well so
share it down the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to Henry
Kaminski jr. Henry thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book through one
word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoyed the read
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
expresso give me go
it's so easy to solve a local problem
you need to dream bigger over and over
again we hear ideas that are interesting
in a local context but they're not big
enough it's a dream bigger right as a
general statement about society we need
to ask the harder questions and we need
to ask for stronger solutions there is a
global emerging consensus around issues
and so forth together we're very strong
it's important to me to have the balls
to look at the biggest problems we face
as a society and say that's my problem
to solve right obesity metabolic disease
the slide towards ill health however you
want to categorize it that's my problem
like I don't even wake up thinking
that's my business partners problem
that's my problem I'm working with my
business partners because of very sharp
guys yeah but at the end of the day like
I own that responsibility and that's
awesome to me right like having that it
isn't a weight that drags me down it's
like this goal to chase that's so big
that I'm just stoked that there are
people in the world debt are prepared to
dream that big like I'm inspired by that
in others and hopefully can inspire
other people with our dream and the
first and foremost important thing about
running your own race is dreaming big
and here I'm called back to my childhood
when I was just starting elementary
school at that point in time the Capri
McCourt had just ruled that public
school districts could pursue
desegregation by using forced busing to
achieve racial balance in their schools
in fact I started my own education as a
first grader being bused to a school
across town even though my father was a
principal at a school five blocks away
although I was a live subject in one of
the nation's most controversial legal
debates I frankly didn't know what the
big deal was all about because these
kids who didn't look like me sure acted
just like me but desegregation was a big
deal to my parents and leaders of their
generations knew a great knew that great
change was in store and it was the right
thing to do and they often met with
resistance and often violent resistance
but because of their struggle their
sacrifice I received a great gift and
that's the gift to dream
I knew my history I remembered the pride
of my mother telling about when she took
me and my brother brought us back to
Washington DC and held me as a
nine-month-old
during the march on Washington when
Martin Luther King laid out his dream
for equal and harmonious meritocratic
America and dreaming big to me meant
knowing my history but not being bound
by it it meant harnessing the past to
drive me into the future
it meant grounding myself and who I was
and where I came from so I could soar to
become who I wanted to become if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details